dans nord ça va mal la surprise c'est
que ça va plus mal payés
[Musique]
en 1967 le chômage a doublé vrai je ne
crois tu pas les cinquante mille
travailleurs chiffres officiels le nord
et sept pour cent des travailleurs de
france et 12 % des chômeurs de france
c'est une surprise comme en or cette
région pilote cette espèce de roue en 16
at il pu en arriver là et bien
simplement parce que les trois
industries de base qui ont fait la
richesse de cette région charbon le
textile la sidérurgie en font maintenant
sinon la pauvreté du moins apporte la
menace d'une décadence progressive
n'était au fond en 36 langues faut alors
comment ça se passe maintenant par
acheteur mais je suis sorti de
l'ordinaire à votre mais j'ai macho il
vient de partir à l'armée quand ils
n'arrêtent pas écrit ce qui va retrouver
bien rien de prévu pour les causes des
clichés qui est responsable cruchot chez
biotherm men est fausse mais on aurait
dû prévenir du boulot douche est jeune
on ne réduit implanter des usines tout
partout qu'est ce qu'on va faire je n'ai
corac ces gens arrivent à l'école quand
tu quand tu es jolie voir l'ag de
travailler hier la police
jetant sa ferme aujourd'hui comme ça ils
saboter tout est votre six étaient
d'accord pour aller à la mine lui a
sûrement un éminent réparatrice
tout le monde il ya passé d'alpha mais
aujourd'hui on arrive à un point ya rien
y'a plus rien qu'est-ce qu'il vous
inspire ce mineur qui s'inquiète pour
son fils c'est tellement sincère quand
il parle et c'est tellement encore comme
ça aujourd'hui il n'ya plus les mines
heureusement
bas wilson ne peut regretter les mines
de charbon fabien roussel non mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que vous allez
mineurs ils étaient fiers de leur
travail c'était dur il y laisser la vie
mais ils étaient fiers fiers de leur
travail de vivre de leur travail et y
compris fier d'avoir chauffer toute la
france au lendemain de la guerre
souvenez vous que les français se
souviennent que les mineurs en 45 46 ont
travaillé gratuitement les dimanches les
jours de congés pour pouvoir chauffer
les hôpitaux les écoles parisiennes
notamment parce que c'était le lendemain
au lendemain de la guerre il y avait
plus rien ils l'ont fait ils étaient
fiers de cette histoire là et pourtant
avec l'ouverture du marché européen
notamment la ceca et compagnie la
sidérurgie à fermer les mines ont fermé
sans prévoir d'industrie nouvelles comme
on l'a vu sur une des pancartes
aujourd'hui on vit la même chose quand
une usine de bridgestone à béthune
c'est le bassin minier ferme comme on
l'a vu il ya quelques mois pour 800
hommes et femmes qui travaillent là
dedans c'est la fin de la vie
c'est pour eux le travail c'est la vie
il faut comprendre ça le travail c'est
la vie et quand on prive les gens de
leur travail on les tue c'est dramatique
et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait de ce
combat pour l'industrie pour l'emploi le
le coeur de mon combat parce que ça me
touche j'ai pour moi c'est l'humanité
elle est là cet homme c'est le genre
humain pourquoi le parti communiste at
il perdu ses bastions éprouvé par la
crise on n'a pas perdu d'abord il ya pas
de bastions il y en a un j'aime pas ce
terme il n'y a pas deux bastions parce
que c'est les gens qui nous élisent sa
tombe pas du ciel et donc les maires qui
était
lé maire communiste de ces villes
c'était des anciens mineurs c'était des
anciens sidérurgistes
ils travaillaient parfois à la fosse et
les habitants les faisait élire maire
quand il se présentait parce qu'ils
avaient besoin de quelqu'un qui la
représente bien qu'ils les défendent et
donc c'était ça qui faisait notre force
et quand on tue le travail quand on
ferme les usines ah bah oui c'est plus
dur pour un parti comme nous qui
représente justement le travail et les
usines mais
nous avons montré lors des dernières
élections départementales notamment que
nous pouvions regagné regagné en
défendant lui monde du travail regagné
justement en présentant des élus issus
du monde du travail et c'est ce que nous
avons fait dans le bassin minier
[Musique]